bonsoir le journal de tv 78 pour faire
le tour de l'actualité locale nous
sommes le jeudi 22 avril tout de suite
les titres de cette édition
le cap a été franchi la semaine dernière
plus de cent mille personnes sont
décédées du colis de 19 en france un
traumatisme sans précédent pour les
familles qui ont perdu un proche et qui
pour beaucoup d'entre elles n'ont pas pu
faire leurs adieux nous en parlons avec
l'association curve id 19 reportage
également auprès des pompes funèbres qui
ont dû faire face à de nombreuses
adaptations plus d'un an après le début
de cette crise sanitaire des chaînes de
solidarité se poursuivent et notamment
celle de vos gâteaux qui distribue des
pâtisseries aux pompiers personnels du
samu ou à la population dans le besoin
focus sur la timba nos filles qui
oeuvrent au mesnil-le-roi et
maisons-laffitte
enfin à sartrouville une ferme urbaine
bientôt créée elle prendra place dans un
parking souterrain une start up est à
l'origine de ce projet qui a pour
vocation est de produire des fruits
légumes salade ou encore aromates et
jean castex prend la parole ce jeudi
soir le premier ministre s'exprime sur
la crise sanitaire
dans un contexte toujours tendu près de
35000 nouvelles contaminations hier aux
copies de 19 3 113 décès elle le
gouvernement qui doit faire des annonces
à quelques jours de la rentrée des
classes en présentiel pour les élèves de
primaire et de maternelle est le
confinement est toujours un plat
jusqu'au 3 mai le gouvernement hier qui
au sortir de son conseil et de défense a
détaillé le calendrier et de levée des
restrictions fin notamment de
l'interdiction de déplacement de dix
kilomètres à plus de dix kilomètres de
son domicile et ce à partir du 3 mai
enfin également de l'interdiction des
déplacements entre les régions nous vous
tiendrons informés d'ici la fin de ce
journal sur les nouvelles annonces que
son fait ce soir par le gouvernement
la semaine dernière la france a dépassé
le cap des cent mille morts dus qu'aux
villes les pompes funèbres ont dû faire
face depuis un an à de nombreuses
adaptations mise en bière sur le lieu de
desserts impossibilité de faire des
soins de conservation des enterrements
sans famille
retour sur ces événements qui ont pu
être traumatisant à magny les hameaux et
c'est avec astrid bergère et joe sakal
le coc vide a bouleversé le quotidien et
les pratiques des professionnels du
funéraire à magny les hameaux les pompes
funèbres van dyck ont repris un rythme
relativement normal mais il garde un
traumatisme de la première vague on ne
faisait plus de transport de corps avant
mise en bière
donc dans une ou sanitaires à visage
découvert mais on faisait ont pratiqué
les mises en bière sur place sur le lieu
du décès sans présence famille tous
étaient aussi là c'est traumatisant pour
le personnel un des pompes funèbres
parce que c'est pas facile de devenir
comme ça et puis de faire une mise en
bière immédiatement de fermer un
cercueil
on sent bien qui va manquer quelque
chose à la famille le jour et nuit entre
mars et mai 2020 il était appelé les
décès s'enchaîner à l'hôpital on vient
d'arriver il ya déjà un corbillard qui
est parti avant nous et puis quand on
vient
m le cercle non dans notre de notre
corbières il ya déjà un corbillard qui
arrive pourrait donc tout ça c'est assez
traumatisant effectivement il a aussi
fallu accompagner les familles des
défunts plus que d'habitude on a essayé
de faire le trait d'union c'est à dire
le lien entre le défunt et la famille
parce que cette famille qui n'avait pas
vu leurs proches avant la mort au nom de
la mort et après la mort au moment où se
ferment le cercueil
eh bien on n'essaye et peut-être de
commandes de les rassurer de leur
expliquer comment on avait pu prendre le
corps mais aussi faire savoir aux
familles que leurs défunts ont été
respectées on a toujours tenu aussi à
préparer nos cercueil coville ou non
qu'ovide exactement de la même manière
c'est à dire que les capitaux et erreurs
passées
on prenait soin des personnes
aujourd'hui le calme est revenu aux
pompes funèbres indique les mises en
bière même pour des cas qu'ovide peuvent
se faire trois jours après le décès mais
à ce jour les professionnels n'ont
toujours pas d'information sur la
contagiosité du virus post mortem
mais derrière ces statistiques il ne
faut pas oublier qu'il est en premier
lieu des victimes mais aussi leurs
familles pour qui il est difficile voire
impossible de faire le deuil de leurs
proches disparus avec des adieux qui
n'ont pas pu se faire des obsèques avec
une petite jauge on en parle avec julie
grasset bonsoir pense à vous êtes la
présidente de l'association curve id 19
son but soutenir les familles de
victimes du côté de 19 vous battez a
notamment pour la création d'un hommage
national aux victimes à leurs familles
mais aussi en remerciement des soignants
cette association à l'aîné de votre
histoire personnelle la mort de votre
père emporté lors de la première vague
du colis de 19 en mars 2020 vous n'avez
pas pu lui dire au revoir vous n'avez
même pas eu le temps de faire votre
deuil et votre histoire est en fait
celle de beaucoup d'autres familles le
sentiment que vous avez ressenti c'est
celui de la de la détresse absolue c'est
ce que ressentent ces familles tout à
fait moi je
j'ai perdu mon père donc lors de la
première vague le 25 mars 2020
j'apprécie d'ailleurs la délicatesse de
l'opérateur funéraire qui vient de
témoigner
j'aurais aimé que mon papa puisse être
accompagné par par cet opérateur
pour ma part mon père a été mis en bière
immédiatement comme le protocole le
voulait à cette époque néanmoins il a
été envoyé à la crémation le jour de son
décès ce qui est totalement interdit
aujourd'hui je milite au travers de mon
association pour effectivement un
hommage national pour que nous puissions
rendre leur dignité à nos proches
il faut savoir que les protocoles
funéraire on croyait la dignité de nos
proches qui leur ont volé la mort et
nous ils nous ont volé notre deuil comme
d'écouter ce monsieur lors de votre
reportage ne les avons pas vus nous ne
savons même pas si c'est eux que nous
avons enterré et aujourd'hui je lance un
cri d'alarmé
aussi tout particulièrement sur le
nécessaire soutien psychologique des
familles de victimes qui vivent un deuil
traumatique mais qui est à votre sens
aujourd'hui inexistant on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler vous parliez de
ses droits funéraire justement
l'association soutient ces familles et
et les aident les accompagnent dans le
respect de ses droits pour le protocole
funéraire s'ils ont été trop souvent
bafouée pendant ces sept années de crise
sanitaire alors particulièrement lors de
la première vague
il faut savoir que les protocoles
l'ensemble des protocoles sanitaires
dont le protocole funéraires ont été
déployés dans l'urgence est de ce fait
le déploiement a été accompagnée parfois
bon an mal an sur les territoires et a
été aussi parfois sujet à des
surinterprétations de la part de
collectivités territoriales ou
d'opérateurs finale comme ce fut le cas
de mon père et je précise que sur la
première vague
la mise en bière immédiate et d'être
imposé le conseil d'état très récemment
a mis fin à cette mise en bière
immédiate aujourd'hui les proches
peuvent voir à quelques centimètres le
visage de leurs proches avant la
fermeture de la housse
mais sur la première vague si vous
voulez nous avons essuyé les plâtres et
si je puis dire
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans un deuil
impossible pourquoi avoir créé votre
association elle a été créée les statuts
ont été déposés en octobre 2020 c'est le
besoin d'échanger de libérer aussi en
quelque sorte la parole ba aujourd'hui
si vous voulez c'est très simple un an
après vous voyez bien il ya toujours
aucune considération pour les pour nos
proches d'une part puisque toujours à la
communication autour de cette logique
comptable et mortifère et puis les
familles des victimes
j'ai beau réécouter les quelques
allocutions et chef de l'état on n'en
parle pas donc cette association et je
les crée et je ne suis pas la seule dans
un premier temps pour que les familles
puissent échanger et puisse soutenir
aussi mutuellement dans la douleur je le
répète on fait face un deuil traumatique
parce que nous n'avons pas vu les nôtres
nous ne savons pas si nous les avons
enterré et cette étape de du droit au
visage et de l'adieu elle est éminemment
importante pour les deuils et
aujourd'hui nous si vous voulez on ne
peut pas accéder à ce processus de deuil
donc un première dans un premier temps
effectivement un espace de partage de
témoignages un hommage parce que
vraiment je crois qu'il faut le dire
l'envers du décor des protocoles c'est
nos proches ont perdu leur dignité ont
vraiment été maltraités et donc il faut
il faut les honorer il faut parler d'eux
il faut parler des hommes et des femmes
qui sont derrière ces chiffres
et puis aujourd'hui c'est aussi si vous
voulez un cri d'alarmé parce qu'il n'y a
aucune cellule psychologique et les
assurances ont soigné les familles
justement c'est pour ça que vous vous
passez ce cri des landes
voilà et les associations arrive en fait
aujourd'hui au bout de ce qu'elles
peuvent faire puisque finalement la
seule réponse pour les familles c'est la
constitution par la société civile par
les individus comme moi et tant d'autres
qui ont créé des pages facebook des
sites internet des collectifs pour
pouvoir s'entraider et données en est
échange de témoignages des réponses à
des questions parfois effectivement sur
les protocoles qui ont été mis en oeuvre
puisque à ce stade l'état n'a fourni
aucune offre à la fois d'accompagnement
et de soins pour l'ensemble des femmes
victimes
qu'est ce que vous demandez par exemple
la mise en place de ce qu'on a pu voir
pour les étudiants un chèque
psychologique pour ces familles afin de
ne pouvoir être accompagné justement
psychologiquement suite à ce deuil
abba concrètement aujourd'hui avec
excusez moi mais je vais être un petit
peu creux nous avons aujourd'hui une
couverture médiatique puisque il a fallu
atteindre la barre donc des cent mille
morts donc ce qui ce qui a jugé été jugé
comme inacceptable par par monsieur
macron donc cent mille morts et un tweet
mais toujours pas effectivement d'offre
de soins et un accompagnement digne de
ce nom et c'est vraiment à se demander
s'il faut effectivement que peut-être
des familles de victimes à s'immoler par
le feu devant le ministère de la santé
des solidarités ou se suicident puisque
je précise que toutes les associations
reçoivent des témoignages déchirants
alarmant de gens qui n'ont pas forcément
les moyens d'aller se payer des séances
de psychothérapie voire de psychiatrie
donc il ya urgence à accompagner aussi
les familles jeu quand je parle de cri
d'alarmé je je je pèse mes mots là on va
vraiment droit à peut-être
malheureusement une vague psychiatrique
avec des duos et aux dommages
collatéraux en fait il ya ces protocoles
qui nous ont aussi ancien militant merci
julie grasset d'être venu le dire dans
ce journal j'en ai le tv 78 je rappelle
que vous êtes la présidente de
l'association coeur dit 19 pour plus
d'informations sur cette association
j'invite les téléspectateurs à se rendre
sur la page facebook dont le lien
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et dans
l'actualité la campagne de vaccination
contre le coc u19 qui se poursuit hier
mercredi dans les yvelines la barre des
229 milles primo vaccinale était
franchie elle la campagne est ouverte
depuis quelques jours aux plus de 55 ans
avec des créneaux sans rendez vous pour
les publics prioritaires avec
astrazeneca aux professeurs
professionnels de la petite enfance de
la protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
les forces de l'ordre
sont venus s'ajouter une dizaine
d'autres professions conducteurs de bus
de taxi vtc livreur chauffeur routier ou
encore agent d'entretien d'autres
professions également ce samedi 24 et
dimanche 25 avril défilent prioritaires
et son rendez-vous et sans rendez-vous
seront ouvertes dans les centres de
vaccination de saint germain en laye de
poissy une carte professionnelle une
déclaration sur l'honneur ou un bulletin
de salaire seront demandés informations
complémentaires et liste des professions
concernées sur le site internet de la
préfecture des yvelines au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
transformer en vaccinodromes la barre
des 50 5500 vaccine a été franchie hier
mercredi est l'occasion pour le
président du département pierre bédier
de saluer le personnel mobilisé en
compagnie de jean michel fourgous
président de saint quentin en yvelines
et des élus locaux pierre bédier en a
profité pour recevoir une injection
plus de 200 personnes sont vaccinées par
jour sur place et le centre de
vaccination voudrait augmenter ses
capacités les propos recueillis par
sediag à 200 go ce vaccinodromes est une
très très belle réussite
c'est une réussite de l'équipe
de gouvernance de saint quentin en
yvelines et en particulier de son
président qui s'est mobilisé dès le
début avec cette idée pour ne pas dire
cette obsession de la vaccination
partant du principe que la lutte contre
l'épidémie passait d'abord par la
vaccination
et d'ailleurs c'est l'une des annonces
en ce moment même de jean castex premier
ministre qui s'exprime sur la crise
sanitaire d'ici la fin de la semaine le
premier ministre a annoncé qu'il y
aurait 14 millions de personnes
vaccinées et ce dans la france entière
un an après le début de la crise
sanitaire la chaîne solidaire vos
gâteaux poursuit son action le principe
la distribution de pâtisseries aux
pompiers personnels du samu ou à toute
personne dans le besoin rencontre avec
la timba nos filles qui oeuvrent de
maisons laffitte au mesnil-le-roi et
c'est avec nicolas landry là ce sont des
macarons à la framboise
j'en ai fait au moins je pense six ans
depuis le depuis le premier confinement
c'est son engagement solidaire dans le
contexte actuel florence le turc réalise
des pâtisseries pour les personnes
mobilisées face à la crise sanitaire et
quelques c'est quelque chose qui est
ancré en moi c'est le plaisir de faire
plaisir le plaisir d'apporter du
réconfort et et c'est quelque chose qui
me porte et qui ne portent tout dans
cette chaîne solidaire en tous les cas
puisque l on le fait depuis longtemps
maintenant enfin depuis plus d'un an
avec elle une vingtaine de personnes
pâtissent au sein de la team banos fit
une équipe basée entre maisons laffitte
et le mesnil le roi engagés dans la
chaîne solidaire vos gâteaux
ce jour là les gâteaux vaut prendre la
direction de plusieurs casernes de
pompiers montesson mesnil-le-roi et
houilles la récolte des pâtisseries se
fait place de l'église
[Musique]
le kouglof magnifique à muffins ce
banane chocolat parfois chocolat trop
sympa merci bonjour
direction ensuite la caserne de houille
sartrouville pour florence le turc
les soldats du feu ont l'embarras du
choix parmi ces gourmandises sa réel
plaisir de recevoir autant de jolies
choses c'est à dire des petites choses
mais finalement ce n'est pas forcément
le cas ce qu'il y en a tellement que ça
vient des grosses aux nous ça nous
apporte quand même tous d'amour dans
tout ça pour la timba nofit la
mobilisation se poursuit
la crise sanitaire le début de cette
histoire saupoudrait de bonne humeur et
nappez d'humanité transport avec
l'ouverture ce jeudi de la plate forme
de remboursement du pas si ma giner
étudiant en ile-de-france mobilité a
décidé de dédommager à hauteur de 85
euros les 500 milles détenteurs de ce
forfait et des jeunes qui ont vu leurs
déplacements être fortement réduits dans
la région avec les confinements
couvre-feu et cours à distance
sont concernés les détenteurs d'une
carte imagin'r annuel ayant souscrit
leur abonnement pour l'année 2020 2021
et 2019 2020 les lycéens ne sont pas
concernés aient les demandes de
remboursement sont à effectuer jusqu'au
21 juin sur la plateforme mon
dédommagement imaginaire point fr
direction sartrouville à présent ou une
ferme urbaine est en pleine création
l'originalité elle prendra place dans un
parking souterrain
c'est la start-up chant perchée qui
s'est lancé dans ce projet fou bientôt
salade aromates en tout genre ou encore
fruits et légumes y seront produits le
reportage d'eléonore sinoquet de joe
sakal c'est encore en plein chantier
mais bientôt dans ce parking sous
terrain désaffecté de la cité des indes
à sartrouville
on y trouvera des salades des aromates
ou encore des fruits et des légumes
la start-up chant perché créée par deux
frères est en train d'installer une
ferme urbaine dans 1300 m² de sous sol
le fait d'être en parking et 2
en général en intérieur et encore plus
en sous sol permet d'avoir et de
bénéficier en fait d'une isolation
naturelle
on a une chape en dalles en béton très
épaisse et presque un mètre de terre au
sud non ce qui permet d'avoir une
température beaucoup plus stable tout en
ondes année autre originalité le mode de
culture la ferme urbaine sera
ambiophonie une technique de culture
hors sol qui mélange l'agriculture
biologique l'hydroponie et la
permaculture cela permet de produire à
la verticale 700 m² seront dédiés aux
plantations l'équivalent d'un champ de
24 hectares c'était vraiment essentiel
même si on fait de la culture en
intérieur sans terre sans lumière
naturelle de respecter les principes de
la permaculture et de la biodiversité
donc on va essayer d'insérer le maximum
de vies dans ces espaces afin
d'atteindre un équilibre naturel comme
on aurait en extérieur emprunt champ
la start-up chant perche qui n'en est
pas à son coup d'essai une première
ferme et des jambes fonctionnement à
paris ce qui a permis de trouver de
nouveaux financements 2,2 millions
d'euros pour celle de sartrouville
on a déjà une trentaine de variétés
d'aromates plusieurs salade une
vingtaine de variétés micro push et le
but ça va être de diversifier beaucoup
les fruits et légumes
le gros défi de cette ferme c'est
d'arriver à faire pousser des tomates
des melons et ce même au mois de
décembre
les travaux devraient se terminer d'ici
fin juin et les premières cultures
seront disponibles à la fin de l'été la
ferme urbaine vendra ses produits en
circuit court dans un rayon de 15 km
autour du parking souterrain
quelques nouvelles du rover persévérance
qui poursuit ses missions sur la planète
mars la mission pour rappel intègre
l'outil supercable l'instrument est
développé en partie par le latmos le
laboratoire atmosphères observations
spatiales installé à guyancourt
persévérance est parvenu à une prouesse
fabriquer cinq grammes d'oxygène en
transformant du dioxyde de carbone
issues de l'atmosphère martienne c'est
une première historique sur une autre
planète
ce processus pourrait permettre à
l'avenir d'éviter de transporter depuis
la terre de larges quantités d'oxygène
et de faciliter ainsi l'envoi futur
d'astronautes sur place ça fait rêver un
mot de sport pour refermer ce journal et
plus particulièrement du tennis de table
avec un club en plein développement son
nom c'est le scalping qui rassemble les
il de voisins-le-bretonneux trappe
villepreux la verrière et magny les
hameaux et qui grandit au point même de
créer un pôle national et ce à partir de
septembre prochain une chance
considérables notamment pour la section
handisport le reportage de bixente mejia
santis tebbal ce sont quasiment les
seuls à avoir pu reprendre les
entraînements en salle
la section handisport du scalping
s'entraîne tous les jours de 11h à 17h
ouverte en 2015 elle rassemble des
joueurs avec différents handicaps
physiques
c'est vraiment assez récent que je peux
journée handisport parce qu'en fait
finale pendant une dizaine d'années chez
leur père valley c'est pas forcément de
grands espoirs et je laisse ça a été un
vrai plaisir car le club a ouvert son
élection le 10 sport pour justement
connaître quelque chose de nouveau que
je connaissais pas du tout on ouvre
cette porte tous types de handicaps et
tout type de handicap peut se mouvoir
ici et puis pouvoir profiter de
l'expérience de geoffrey millions de
l'expérience des coaches qui s'y sont
habilités à cette année dix à vingt
joueurs inscrits dont certains vis des
titres nationaux dans leur catégorie un
nombre qui va augmenter avec la création
d'un pôle handi sport dès septembre
prochain
cette structure a pour objectif de
regrouper au même endroit
des jeunes ou moins jeunes qui ont un
potentiel d'intégrer plus ou moins
l'équipe de france à moyen ou long terme
avec possibilité de gérer la scolarité
en même temps symbole de cette réussite
florence siro présidente du club elle
est également en lice pour participer
aux jo paralympiques de tokyo parmi ces
projets une compétition internationale
handisport au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
ce tournoi va s'inscrire dans de
multiples organisations d'événements et
notamment on souhaiterait pouvoir
organiser le tournoi de qualification
des jeux paralympiques pour parler de
1024 le premier sky par att french open
qui devrait rassembler 200 pongiste
handisport aura lieu du 9 au 11 novembre
2021 avant de vous laisser la prise de
parole ce soir du gouvernement jean
castex a terminé de s'exprimer c'est
désormais olivier ferrand le ministre de
la santé des solidarités qui s'exprime
sur la crise sanitaire je le rappelle
une prise de parole toujours dans un
contexte tendu près de 35000 nouvelles
contaminations hier au colis de 19 dans
les yvelines
643 patients étaient hospitalisés hier
dans le territoire sur le territoire et
18 décès supplémentaires ont été
recensés parmi les annonces à retenir ce
soir du gouvernement déjà une
confirmation celui celle du calendrier
du déconfinement à partir du 3 mai et
des reprises de déplacement qui pourront
se faire au delà des 10 km de la jauge
des 10 km qui était fixé autour de son
domicile reprise également des
déplacements inter régions et ce à
partir du 3 m des annonces également
pour les écoles avec une reprise reprise
des écoles pour les élèves de primaire
et maternelle qui a été confirmé en
présentiel et ce pour lundi prochain
c'est à dire le 26 avril une reprise
pour les collégiens et les lycéens qui
se ferait le 26 avril en distance yale
mais qui est confirmé à l'heure où je
vous parle le 3 mai en présentiel donc
pour les lycéens et les collégiens pas
de calendrier en revanche annoncer un
pour le moment pour la réouverture des
terrasses des lieux culturels également
des commerces dits non essentiels enfin
la dernière annonce et je vous le disais
tout à l'heure à d'ici la fin de la
semaine 14 millions de personnes
auraient été vaccinées en france un
rythme de 2,5 millions de personnes
vaccinées par semaine en france voilà ce
qu'on pouvait vous dire autour de ces
annonces des annonces qu'on vous
détaillera dans de prochaines éditions
sur tv 78 c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité très belle
soirée avec tv 70
[Musique]